The component marketplace is real and more continue to grow.
This is going to bring customers the benefits of well-defined, tested and
supported, and documented solutions.
Nevertheless, there are some ongoing concerns that need to be addressed.
How about liability?
When a system that uses a component fails, how is liability apportioned among
all the vendors that have provided components to it?
Quality guarantees.
How can cross cutting quality of service requirements be addressed in
a multiple component environment?
If the quality of service has to do with performance which of
the components is responsible for providing the performance guarantees?
Well all of them.
And the third question to be looked at.
Contract persistent over versions.
What is the white balance between new versions and support for
incompatible exis, existing features?